let's go next to I don't know if it's
nitin or nitin from uh New York
however it is pronounced I hope that we
can figure it out welcome to the program
hey David this is nitin here from New
York though I'm currently in
Pennsylvania that's still allowed
no problem I just had a quick question
about Rome's history of frivolous
lawsuits yeah what does he get out of
from them like why does he like
typically file him you know especially I
remember you know him filing around 65
or so frivolous lawsuits that were all
like left out left and right Etc in
court but you're saying in response to
the 2020 election does he aim to do so
there's different categories
yeah there's different categories of
these lawsuits the 65 or 63 or whatever
the number was filed in response to the
2020 election
he needed to file those because he was
raising money on I'm going to be doing
this and I'm going to be fighting to
turn it over and whatever if he raises
all this money and then files nothing it
doesn't look quite so good so he was
filing them because he was raising money
to do it now the lawsuits where like
Jesus big tech for 300 million or
whatever the case may be those seem more
like virtue signaling than they are for
for sort of like grifting purposes so
you have to look specifically at which
ones you're talking about
got you but you know but in general like
you know I looked up his legal
strategies and you know like for the
most part it's mainly about you know
harassing opponents just to intimidate
them or like you know using it as a
stall tactic 100 that is absolutely what
it is about in many cases many times
it's counter suits to prevent some
lawsuit against him from moving forward
there's like a real all of the above
sort of situation going on with them but
um they seem to be relatively
ineffective at least in the last five
years
gotcha yeah
all right anything else today
tell it uh nothing else all right very
good I appreciate the call your videos
okay Newton from York we're starting to
get a bit of a delay that was causing
some awkward exchanges